okay so let me uh let's go like far into
the future let's imagine this gigantic
neuromorphic computing system
that uh simulates all of our realities
it currently is mentioned matrix four so
this thing
uh this powerful computer
how does it operate like so so what what
are the neurons
what is the communication what's your
sense all right so let me let me now
after spending 45 minutes trashing light
source integration with silicon let me
now say why i'm basing my entire life
yeah professional life on
integrating light sources with
electronics i think the game is
completely different when you're talking
about superconducting electronics for
several reasons um
let me try to go through them one is
that as i mentioned it's difficult to
integrate those compound semiconductor
light sources with silicon with silicon
is a requirement that is introduced by
the fact that using semiconducting
electronics in superconducting
electronics you're still going to start
with a silicon wafer but it's it's just
the bread for your sandwich in a lot of
ways you're not using that silicon in
precisely the same way for the
electronics you're now depositing
superconducting materials on top of that
the prospects for integrating light
sources with that kind of an electronic
process are
certainly less explored but i think much
more promising because you don't need
those light sources to be intimately
integrated with the transistors that's
where the problems come up they don't
need to be lattice matched to the
silicon all that kind of stuff instead
it seems possible that you can take
those compound semiconductor light
sources
stick them on the silicon wafer and then
grow your superconducting electronics on
the top of that it's at least not
obviously going to fail so the
computation would be done on the
superconductive material as well yes the
computation is done in the
superconducting electronics
and the light sources receive signals
that say hey a neuron reach threshold
produce a pulse of light send it out to
all your downstream synaptic connections
those are again super conductive elect
superconducting electronics perform your
computation
and you're off to the races your network
works so then if we can rewind real
quick so what are the limitations of the
challenges of super conducting
electronics
when we think about constructing these
kinds of systems so
actually let me let me say uh one other
thing about the light sources yes please
and then i'll then i'll move on i
promise because this is this is probably
tedious first this is super exciting
okay one other thing about the light
sources i said that silicon is terrible
at emitting photons it's just not what
it's meant to do however the game is
different when you're at low temperature
if you're working with superconductors
you have to be at low temperature
because they don't work otherwise when
you're at 4 kelvin silicon is not
obviously a terrible light source it's
still not as efficient as compound
semiconductors but it might be good
enough for this application
the final thing that i'll mention about
that is again leveraging superconductors
as i said
in in a different context
superconducting detectors can receive
one single photon
in that conversation i failed to mention
that semiconductors can also receive
photons that's the primary mechanism by
which it's done a camera in your phone
that's receptive to visible light it's
is receiving photons it's based on
silicon or you can make it in different
semiconductors for different wavelengths
but it requires on the order of a
thousand a few thousand photons to
receive a pulse
now when you're using a superconducting
detector you need one photon exactly one
i mean
one or more
so
the fact that your synapses can now be
based on superconducting detectors
instead of semiconducting detectors
brings the light levels that are
required down by some three orders of
magnitude so now
you don't need good light sources you
can have the world's worst light sources
as long as they spit out maybe a few
thousand photons every time a neuron
fires
you have
the heart you have the hardware
principles in place that you might be
able to do perform this optoelectronic
integration to me optoelectronic
integration has it's just so enticing we
want to be able to leverage electronics
for computation light for communication
working with silicon microelectronics at
room temperature that has been
exceedingly difficult
and i hope that when we move to the
superconducting domain target a
different application space that is
neuromorphic instead of digital
and use superconducting detectors
maybe optoelectronic integration comes
to us okay so there's a bunch of
questions so one is temperature
so in these kind of hybrid heterogeneous
systems
what's the temperature what are some of
the constraints to the operation here
does it all have to be a four kelvin as
well four kelvin everything has to be at
four kelvin
okay so what are the other engineering
challenges of making this kind of
optoelectronic systems
let me just dwell on that for kelvin for
a second because some people here for
kelvin and they just get up and leave
they just say i don't i'm not doing it
you know and to me that's very
earth-centric species-centric we live in
300 kelvin so we want our technologies
to operate there too i totally get it
yeah what's zero celsius zero celsius is
273 kelvin so
we're talking very very cold here this
is this is even boston cold
this is real cold yeah siberia cold no
okay so just for reference the the
temperature of the cosmic microwave
background is about 2.7 kelvin so we're
still
warmer than deep space
good so that when the universe
dies out
it'll be colder than 4k it's already
colder than 4k in the in the expanses
you know you don't have to get that far
away from the earth in order to to drop
down to not far from what you're saying
is the aliens that live at the edge
of the observable universe
are using superconductive material for
their computation they don't have to
live at the edge of the universe the
aliens that are more advanced than us
in their solar system are
doing this
in their asteroid belt
we can get to that oh
because of the they can get that to that
temperature easier there sure yeah all
you have to do is reflect the sunlight
away and you have a huge head start oh
so the sun is the problem here yeah like
it's warm here on earth yeah okay okay
so can you uh so how do we get to 4k
what's well though okay so very
different kind of 4k temperature yeah
what i want to say about temperature is
that
if you can swallow that if you can say
all right i give up
applications that have to do with my
cell phone
and the convenience of
you know a laptop on a train and you
instead
for me i'm i'm very much in the
scientific headspace i'm not looking at
products i'm not looking at what this
would be useful to sell to consumers
instead i'm thinking about scientific
questions well it's just not that bad to
have to work at 4 kelvin we do it all
the time in our labs at nist and so does
i mean
for reference the entire quantum
computing
sector
usually has to work at something like
100 millikelvin 50 millikelvin so now
you're talking another factor of 100
even colder than that a fraction of a
degree and everybody seems to think
quantum computing is going to take over
the world
it's so much more expensive to have to
get that extra
factor
of 10 or whatever colder
and yet it's not stopping people from
investing in in that area and by
investing i i mean putting their
research into it as well as venture
capital or whatever so oh so so based on
the energy of what you're commenting on
i'm getting a sense that's one of the
criticism of this approach is 4k for
kelvin
is uh is a big negative it is the
showstopper for a lot of people they
just i mean and understandably i i'm not
saying that
that that's not a consideration of
course it is for for some okay so
different motivations for different
people in the academic world suppose you
spent your whole life learning about
silicon microelectronic circuits you you
send a design to a foundry they send you
back a chip
and you go test it at your tabletop
and now i'm saying here now how learn
how to use all these cryogenics so you
can do that at 4 kelvin
no come on man i want to do that that
sounds it's the old momentum the titanic
or the turning yeah kind of but you're
saying that's not that too much of a
finding when we're looking at large
systems and the gain you can potentially
get from them that's not that much of a
cost and when you want to answer the
scientific question about what are the
physical limits of cognition
well the physical limits they don't care
if you're at 4 kelvin if you can perform
cognition at a scale orders of magnitude
beyond any room temperature technology
but you got to get cold to do it
you're going to do it and to me that's
the interesting
application space
it's not even an application space
that's the interesting scientific
paradigm
so i i personally am not going to let
low temperature stop me from realizing
a technological
domain or
realm that is
achieving in most ways everything else
that i that i'm looking for in my
hardware so that okay that's a big one
is there other kind of engineering
challenges that you envision yeah yeah
yeah so
let me take a moment here because i
haven't really described what i mean by
a neuron or a network in this particular
hardware yeah do you want to talk about
loop neurons and there's so many
fascinating but you just have so many
amazing papers that people should
definitely check out and uh the titles
alone are just killers so anyway go
ahead right so let me say big picture
based on optics photonics for
communication super conducting
electronics for computation how how does
this all work so
a neuron in this in this hardware
platform can be thought of as circuits
that are based on joseph's injunctions
like we talked about before where every
time a photon comes in so let's start by
talking about a synapse a synapse
receives a photon one or more from from
a different neuron and it converts that
optical signal to an electrical signal
the amount of current that that adds to
a loop is controlled by the synaptic
weight so as i said before you're
popping fluxons into a loop right so
a photon comes in it hits a
superconducting single photon detector
one photon the the absolute physical
minimum that you can communicate from
one place to another with light and that
detector then converts that to an
electrical signal and the amount of
signal is uh correlated with some kind
of weight yeah so the synaptic weight
will tell you how many fluxons you pop
into the loop it's an analog number
we're doing analog computation now well
okay can you just linger on that what
the heck is the flux on are we supposed
to know this or is this is this a funny
uh is like the big bang is this is this
a funny word for something deeply
technical no let's let's try to avoid
using the word flux line because it's
not actually necessary when a when a
when a photo is fun to say though so uh
so
it's very necessary i would say when
when a photon hits that superconducting
single photon detector
current is added to a superconducting
loop and the the amount of current that
you add can is an analog value can have
eight bit equivalent resolution
something like that
ten bits maybe that's amazing by the way
this is starting to make a lot more
sense when you're using superconductors
for this the energy
of that circulating current is
is less than the energy of that photon
so your
your energy budget is not destroyed by
doing this analog computation
so now in the language of a
neuroscientist you would say that's your
postsynaptic signal you have this
current being stored in a loop you can
decide what you want to do with it most
likely you're going to have it decay
exponentially so
every single synapse is going to have
some given time constant
and that's determined by set by putting
some
resistor in that in that superconducting
loop so a synapse a synapse event occurs
when a photon strikes a detector adds
current to that loop it decays over time
that's the postsynaptic signal then you
can process that in a dendritic tree
bryce primavera and i have a paper
that we've submitted about that
for the more neuroscience oriented
people there's a lot of dendritic
processing a lot of plasticity
mechanisms you can implement with
essentially exactly the same circuits
you have this
one simple building block circuit that
you can use for a synapse for a dendrite
for the neuron cell body for all the
plasticity functions it's all based on
the same building block just tweaking a
couple parameters so this basic building
block has both an optical and an
electrical component and then you could
just
build arbitrary large systems with that
close you're not at fault for thinking
that that's what i meant what i what i
should say is that
if you want it to be a synapse you tack
a detector a superconducting detector
onto the front of it and if you want it
to be anything else there's no optical
component got it so at the front
optics in the front uh electrical stuff
in the back electrical yeah in the
processing and in the the output signal
that it sends to the next stage of
processing
further
so the dendritic trees is electrical
it's all electrical it's all electrical
in the super domain for
anybody who's up on their
superconducting circuits it's just based
on a dc squid the most ubiquitous it's
which is a circuit composed of two
joseph's injunctions so it's it's a very
bread and butter kind of thing and then
the only place where you go beyond that
is the neuron cell body itself it's
receiving all these electrical inputs
from the synapses or dendrites or
however you've structured that
particular unique neuron and when it
reaches its threshold which occurs by
driving a joseph's injunction above its
critical current it produces a pulse of
current which starts an amplification
sequence voltage amplification that
produces light out of a a transmitter so
one of one of our colleagues adam akan
and sonia buckley as well did a lot of
work on the
the light sources and the
amplifiers that drive the current and
produce sufficient voltage to drive
current through that now semiconducting
part so that light source is the
semiconducting part of a neuron
and that so the neuron has reached
threshold it produces a pulse of light
that light then fans out across a
network of wave guides to reach all the
downstream synaptic terminals
that
do perform this process themselves so
it's probably worth explaining what a
network of wave guides is because a lot
of listeners aren't going to know that
look up the papers by jeff chiles on
this one but basically
light can be guided in a
simple basically wire of usually an
insulating material so
silicon silicon nitride
different different kinds of glass just
like in a fiber optic it's glass silicon
dioxide that makes it a little bit big
we want to bring these down so we use
different materials like silicon nitride
but basically just imagine a rectangle
of some material
that just goes and branches um
forms different different branch points
that target different sub-regions of the
network you can transition between
layers of these so now we're talking
about building in the third dimension
which is absolutely crucial so that's
what wave guides are
so yeah that's great uh wha why the
third dimension is crucial
okay so yes you were talking about what
are some of the technical limitations
one of the things that
i believe we have to grapple with is
that
our brains are miraculously compact for
the number of neurons that are in our
brain
it sure does fit in a small volume as it
would have to if we're going to be
biological organisms that are resource
limited and things like that
any kind of hardware neuron is almost
certainly going to be much bigger than
that if it is of comparable complexity
even whether it's based on silicon
transistors okay a transistor seven
nanometers that doesn't mean a
semiconductor based neuron is seven
nanometers they're big they they require
many transistors different other things
like capacitors and things that store
charge they end up being
on the order of a hundred microns by 100
microns and it's difficult to get them
down any smaller than that the same is
true for superconducting neurons and the
same is true if we're trying to use
light for communication even if you're
using electrons for communication
you
you have these wires where
okay the elect the size of an electron
might be angstroms but the size of a
wire is not angstroms and if you try and
make it narrower the resistance just
goes up so it you don't actually win
to communicate over long distances you
need your wires to be
microns wide
and it's the same thing for wave guides
wave guides are essentially limited by
the wavelength of light and that's going
to be about a micron so whereas compare
that to an axon the analogous component
in the brain which is
10 nanometers in diameter something like
that they
they're bigger when they need to
communicate over long distances but
grappling with the size of these
structures is inevitable and crucial and
so
in order to make systems of comparable
scale to the human brain by scale here i
mean number of interconnected neurons
you absolutely have to be using the
third spatial dimension
and that means
on the wafer you need multiple layers of
both active and passive components
active i mean
superconducting electronic circuits
that are performing computations and
passive i mean these wave guides that
are routing the optical signals to
different places you have to be able to
stack those if you can get to something
like
10 planes of each of those or maybe not
even 10 maybe 5 6 something like that
then you're in business now you can get
millions of neurons on a wafer
but that's not that's not anywhere close
to the brain scale in order to get to
the scale of the human brain you're
going to have to also use the third
dimension in the sense that
entire wafers need to be stacked on top
of each other with fiber optic
communication between them and we need
to be able to fill
a space the size of this table with
stacked wafers
and that's when you can get to some 10
billion neurons like your human brain
and i i don't think that's specific to
the optoelectronic approach that we're
taking i think that applies to any
hardware where you're trying to reach
commensurate scale and complexity as the
human brain so you need that fractal
stacking so stacking on the wafer and
stacking of the wafers and then whatever
the system that combined this stacking
of the tables with the wafers and it has
to be fractal all the way you're exactly
right because that's the only way that
you can efficiently get information from
a small point to across that whole
network it has to have the the power law
connected and photons are like uh optics
throughout yeah absolutely once you're
at this scale to me it's just obvious of
course you're using light for
communication you have
fiber optics
given to us you know from nature so
simple
the the thought of even trying to this
any kind of electrical communication
just doesn't
it doesn't make sense to me i'm not
saying it's wrong i don't know but
that's where i'm coming from so let's
return to loop neurons
why are they called loop neurons
yeah the term loop neurons comes from
the fact like we've been talking about
that they rely heavily on these
superconducting loops so
even in
a lot of forms of digital computing with
superconductors storing uh a signal in a
superconducting loop is a a primary
technique
in this particular case it's it's just
loops everywhere you look so the
the strength of a synaptic weight is
going to be set by the state the amount
of current circulating in a loop that is
coupled to the synapse so
memory is
implemented as current circulating in a
superconducting loop
the the coupling between say a synapse
and a dendrite or a synapse in the
neuron cell body occurs through
loop loop coupling through transformer
so current circulating in a synapse is
going to induce current in a in a
different loop a receiving loop in the
in the neuron cell body
so
since all of the computation is
happening in these flux storage loops
and they play such a central role in in
how the information is processed how
memories are formed all that stuff i
didn't think too much about it just call
them loop neurons because it rolls off
the tongue a little bit better than
superconducting optoelectronic neurons
okay so uh how do you design circuits
for these loop neurons that's a great
question there's a lot of different
scales of design so
at the level of just one synapse you can
use conventional methods
they don't they're not that complicated
as as far as superconducting electronics
goes it's just
for joseph's injunctions or something
like that depending on how much
complexity you want to add so you can
just directly simulate each component in
in spice
place it's standard electrical
simulation software okay basically so
you're just you're just explicitly
solving the differential equations that
describe the circuit elements and then
you can stack these things together in
that simulation software to then build
circuits you can but that becomes
computationally expensive so one of the
things when when covet hit we knew we
had to turn some attention to more
things you can do at home in your
basement or whatever and one of them was
was
computational modeling so we started
working on
adapting
abstracting out the circuit performance
so that you don't have to explicitly
solve the circuit equations which for
joseph's injunctions usually needs to be
done on like a picosecond time scale and
you have
a lot of nodes in your circuit so it
results in a lot of differential
equations that need to be solved
simultaneously we were looking for a way
to simulate these circuits
that is scalable up to networks of
millions or so neurons is sort of where
we're targeting right now
so we were able to
analyze the behavior of these circuits
and as i said there it's based on these
simple building blocks so you really
only need to understand this one
building block and if you get a good
model of that boom it tiles and you you
can change the parameters in there to
get different behaviors and stuff but
it's all based on now it's one
differential equation that you need to
solve so
one differential equation for every
synapse dendrite or neuron in your in
your system and for the neuroscientists
out there it's just a simple leaky
integrated fire model
leaky integrator basically the synapse
is a leaky integrator a dendrite is a
leaky integrator so i'm i'm really
fascinated by how
this one simple component
can be used to achieve lots of different
types of dynamical activity
and
to me that's where scalability comes
from and also complexity as well
complexity is often characterized by
relatively simple building blocks
connected in
potentially simple or sometimes
complicated ways and then emergent new
behavior that was hard to predict from
those
simple simple elements and that's
exactly what we're working with here so
it's a very exciting platform
both from a modeling perspective and
from a hardware manifestation
perspective where we can hopefully start
to to have this
uh test bed where we can explore things
not just related to neuroscience but
also related to other things
that connected to other physics like
critical phenomenon icing models things
like that so
you were asking how we simulate these
circuits
it's it's at different levels and we've
got the simple spice circuit
stuff that's no problem and now we're
building these network models based on
this more efficient leaky integrator so
we can actually
reduce every element to one differential
equation and then we can also step
through it on a much coarser time grid
so it ends up being something like a
factor of a thousand to ten thousand
speed improvement which allows us to
simulate but hopefully up to up to
millions of neurons
um whereas before we would have been
limited to
tens 100 something like that and just
like uh simulating quantum mechanical
systems with a quantum computer so the
goal here is to understand
such systems for me
the goal is to study this as a
scientific physical system it i'm not
drawn towards turning this into an
enterprise at this point i actually feel
short-term applications that obviously
make a lot of money is not necessarily a
curiosity driver for you at the moment
absolutely not if you're interested in
short-term making money go with deep
learning use silicon microelectronics if
you want to understand
things like the the physics of a
fascinating system or if you want to
understand
something more along the lines of the
physical limits of what can be achieved
then i think
single photon communication
superconducting electronics
is extremely exciting what if i want to
use superconducting hardware at 4 kelvin
to mine bitcoin that's my main interest
that's that's the reason i wanted to
talk to you today i want us not i don't
know what's what's bitcoin
[Laughter]
it's a
look it up on the internet somebody
somebody told me about it i'm not sure
exactly what it is
you